um i don't like ryan
reynolds at all
[ __ ]
hello there i'm ryan reynolds hi there
i'm jody coma and this is first
impressions or lad bible yes
oh oh oh oh my mommy always said life is
like a box of chocolates forest gum
no life is like a box of active grenades
you never know what you're going to get
why i say everything is sort of like
this
i mean and and his dad sort of talks a
bit like this he says um
i am so sorry because i'm feeling it all
but i can't think of the name
stewie griffin oh
i love this one and this mammal
is david attenborough
we love david after i got a freestyle
one
don't do elmo don't do it elmo don't do
elmo don't do elmo don't do elmo can i
have some more coffee please
can i have some more coffee with jodie
comer she's
one of the most beautiful women oh sean
connery that was great
it wasn't elmo thank god uh
uh i love you wait what
hold on elmo no dear god no please
i love you almost piggy oh oh kermit the
frog
kermit the frog was that good i feel a
little bit confident this piggy helped
um yeah um i don't like
ryan reynolds at all
absolutely [ __ ]
i can't do this you can you can
and you will wait you're doing it right
now you're doing it right now
uh ryan yes whoa really yes oh my god
that's you did a
spot on me wow uh say mr soderbergh
it's a bit about time to take my shirt
off
all right all right all right you got it
that was really good matt damon
who you know does the best mathematical
impression
please what's going on cheryl plenty
more with that camera
i'll say uh this kitchen is a
disaster oh you've got to get it right
again i don't know how to impersonate
him cheat one of the greatest guys
hugh jackman oh i don't know how to do
it it's not hugh jackman
who was it though barack obama oh my god
how do you impersonate him
he sort of talks a bit like this oh yeah
and he likes to throw it back and then
no
he can't have my points oh wow i am not
doing
donald trump all right hey
we've heard enough of him um certainly i
like to go boxing and uh
and knock people out i'm one of the most
what are the greatest fighters of all
time
oh god this this is see now i'm just
down the rabbit hole in this impression
there's no you can't pull this back
i was in the hangover i love fun i sound
like jay leno oh
mike tyson yes does he kiss does he
speak like
i think she's like hey y'all
reese witherspoon tumbled out of bed and
stumbled oh darling
that's my really awful son that i said
a lion wolverine
crocodile a dinosaur
what kind of dinosaur oh i didn't
tyrannosaurus yes
[Music]
i won i've never won anything in my life
oh
god some of that was deeply embarrassing
but you can use all of it
this is all i hear with don't do elmo
don't do elmo don't do elmo do not do
elmo ryan
[Music]
it's not a thing i mean it is a thing
but it's not a thing try your best
um we're in london we're going down the
street
to a funky bee oh the uh and i'm gonna
get a haircut
i have to say you made it three times
you can do whatever you want oh [ __ ]
i was about to be like the streets i was
like he's like
i was like trying to figure
i'm in london i was like we don't freeze
now